وصفت باروع العجائب الهندسيه وتعتبر اغلى
بناء انشاه البشر على الاطلاق بكلفه قدرت
باكثر من 150 مليار دولار انها محطه
الفضاء الدوليه اكبر واهم الانجازات
البشريه
انشئت المحطه الدوليه عام
1998 بموجب تعاون دولي بقياده امريكا
وروسيا وبتمويل من كندا واليابان وعدد من
دول اوروبيه تدور على ارتفاع 390 كيلومترا
تقريبا عن سطح كوكب الارض وبسرعه 28 الف
كيلو متر في الساعه لذا فالمحطه تكمل دوره
واحده حول الارض كل 90 دقيقه وتكمل حوالي
16 دور حول الارض يوميا وبالتالي الشمس
تشرق على روادها وتغربه 16 مره خلال اليوم
الواحد واصبحت ماهوله برواد الفضاء منذ ان
دخلها اول طاقم في نوفمبر تشرين الثاني
عام 2000 المحطه تعتبر مختبرا للابحاث
والتجارب لتحسين نوعيه الحياه على الارض
عن طريق زياده المعرفه العلميه من خلال
الابحاث التي تجرى خارج كوكبنا وقد اطلقت
لتاخذ محل المحطه الفضائيه الروسيه ميرو
ومهامها
في تحضير الانسان لتمضيه اوقات طويله في
الفضاء واجراء التجارب خارج منطقه
الجاذبيه الارضيه
[موسيقى]